when the wildfires surged through the
hills and towards the tiny village of
obario in galicia northwest spain it
stood little chance
not even the stone church hundreds of
years old survived unscathed
and paro corcoba has come back to see
what is left of her life
the house is still smoldering
and it's not safe to go back inside
she doesn't even know if they can
salvage anything
it's very sad very sad indeed she says
my husband inherited this house from his
parents and he built this bit with his
own hands when he was young to make it
bigger so for my husband this really
hurts him and it hurts me too
there is a crisis to recover from but
increasingly a bigger problem to think
about too
as climate change gets worse so will
fire season putting these communities at
risk over and over again and it will
make some people think about whether or
not they want to stay here at all
in the neighboring village of a vega
dica scala one family has had enough
it's the house that my father-in-law
built and it's our family home lila
rodriguez tells me but our intention is
to sell it
it's a pity
but others like roberto rodriguez are
more philosophical
as everything has already burned he says
what is left to burn
i am old and retired where should i go
[Laughter]
i still have a beautiful house
for the moment that is true
but others weren't so lucky and must
pick up the pieces
facing an uncertain future as the danger
posed by climate change grows hannah
thomas peter sky news and galicia in
spain